nadie que le buscara quedarse en el
poder el anuncio del presidente del
salvador llegó en la noche de este
jueves cuando el país celebraba el
aniversario 201 de independencia de
centroamérica ahora que empezamos a
estar bien hay algunos y quiero recalcar
algunos de la comunidad internacional
que empiezan a condenar las mismas
acciones por la que estamos bien no las
decisiones previas las acciones por la
que estamos bien critican la guerra
contra las pandillas critican el régimen
de excepción critican la captura de
pandilleros como si quisiera que
volviéramos a estar mal es por eso que
luego de compensarlo con esposa gabriela
y con mi familia
anuncia el pueblo salvadoreño que he
decido correr como candidato a la
presidencia
con este anuncio bucles se convierte en
el primer presidente del país con la
opción de buscar la reelección inmediata
tras un cambio de criterio hecho por los
magistrados de la sala de lo
constitucional
magistrados que fueron electos por
aliados de buque en el congreso en un
proceso ampliamente cuestionado tras la
destitución de los entonces jueces
titulares y el fiscal general raúl
melara la resolución de septiembre de
2021 modificó la antigua ley que
inhabilitaba del poder a los mandatarios
durante dos periodos consecutivos antes
de intentar volver al poder el día de
independencia también estuvo marcado por
las protestas contra el ejecutivo esta
es la quinta vez en un año que los
salvadoreños salen a las calles a
expresar su rechazo entre otras cosas a
la denominada guerra contra las
pandillas una que el presidente asegura
estar a punto de ganar
los que nos sigan aumentando no queremos
que no sigan acosando el pueblo no
quiere más retrocesos
queremos independencia en los poderes no
queremos la reelección
una ola de violencia registrada en marzo
que cobró la vida de más de 80 personas
fue atribuida directamente a las
pandillas desde entonces el gobierno
pidió a la asamblea legislativa aprobar
la suspensión de garantías
constitucionales y la mano dura de bucle
no se ha detenido según las autoridades
cerca de 52 mil 500 personas han sido
detenidas y acusadas de pertenecer a
grupos delictivos y organizaciones
humanitarias han reportado más de 6.500
denuncias de violaciones de derechos
humanos